all the world's a stage and all the men
and women merely players they have their
exits and their entrances and one man in
his time plays many parts
last week we had a know not him
moment when beloved actor Leonard Nimoy
passed away at the age of 83 he was the
original sci-fi nerd and it's today
you're proud to be a nerd like me then
you have him to thank plus his eyebrows
are on fleek I'm too old to do that I'm
a nice mirror and welcome to hash tag
news Leonard Nimoy was best known for
his role as mr. Spock on the original
Star Trek TV show during his many
adventures through space and time with
the crew of the enterprise we learned
about other galaxies alien races the
Wrath of Khan the trouble with tribbles
but we also learned to be more tolerant
and understanding of others and it was
Spock the voice of reason who guided us
through those adventures
Spock became a staple of nerd culture
and represented the outsider the geek
the different one but he was not ashamed
he was proud and because of that he was
and will remain a role model to many
even Obama our nerdiest president was
quoted as saying cool logical big-eared
and level-headed was he talking about
himself back to the quote he was the
center of Star Trek's optimistic
inclusive vision of humanity's future
I loved Spock but Leonard was not above
poking fun at himself he was a great
guest star and voice on many of our
favorite programs
mr. Spock mr. Spock
mr. Leonard Nimoy ha ha I'd say this
vessel could do at least warp 5 and let
me say may the force be with you do you
even know who I am Spock I need to speak
with you ever mourn the past young
warrior thanks to you our races survived
he was always a wise man and shared his
wisdom with us fellow earthlings he will
always be known for his catchphrase live
long and prosper and I think he did he
will be missed
well that was it for hashtag news
comment below with your fondest memory
of Leonard Nimoy or mr. Spock and please
subscribe for more hash tag news we love
to make these videos and fill you in on
the latest so subscribe and come back
for more that's all beam me up Scotty